영화 한 마디도 못
하 뭔 글러 버리냐 존나 웃기네 뭐
천억짜리 거래도 못 되본 놈들이 존나
깝치네 이렇게 돼 있는데 저 영어 못
해요네 영어 못 하고네 안녕하요
빌사남 있니다 제가 오늘은 댓글
읽기를 좀 해보겠습니다 기존에 좀
댓글 달아 주셨던 거를 좀 정리를
했는데 일단은 뭐 좋은 얘기도 있고
뭐 이렇게 좀 악플 이런 것도 좀
있어요 제가 오늘 뭐 그런 거 좀
상관없이 한번 전체적으로 좀 읽어
보도록 하겠습니다 그때 도쿄 영상을
올렸었는데 어 말씀 들어 보니까
수수료는 상당한 거 같은데 국내보다
세금에 대한 부분이 더 메리트가
있을까요 그리고 엔저 때문에 차액이
더 수월할까 뭐 이런 내용으로 댓글을
남겨 주셨는데 그런 거 같아요 일본
부동산은 뭐 제가 조심스럽게 예상을
해 보면 한국 같은 시장은 좀 아닌
거 같아요 한국은 강남에 괜찮은 거
사면 차익이 막 진짜 단기간에 막
몇십억 아니면 몇백억이 나기도 하지만
여기 일본 같은 경우에는 그렇게 좀
폭발적으로 나거나 뭐 그런 거는 좀
많이 없는 거 같아요 제 개인적으론
그래서 그거보다는 일본 금리가 워낙
낮다 보니까 낮은 금리로 대출을
받아서 소액으로 안정적인 뭔가 수익
이런 거를 좀 생각하고 투자하기에는
좀 괜찮은 거 같은데 일반적으로
우리가 한국 투자들이 하면은 좀 다른
시장 같습니다 일본 같은 경우에는 아
사고 싶네요 어 뭐 시드 어느 정도
있으면 서울에 가능할까요 이렇게
말씀해 주셨는데 사실 되게 소액으로도
할 수 있어요네 할 수 있는데 지금
같은 시장에는 진짜 애매한 거를
사면은 나중에 팔기도 어렵고 임대도
어렵고 덩어리가 될 수도 있거든요
요즘 같은 시기에는 애매한데 살 거면
진짜 좀 안 사는게 낫습니다 최소한의
투자 가치 있는 걸 산다라고 하면은
그래도 현금이 뭐 취득세 이런 것도
다 생각을 해야 되니까 10억에서
15억 정도는 가져고 계셔야 그나마
좀 서울에서 괜찮은 지역에 어 투자할
수 있다라고 저는 생각이 됩니다
그래서 전에 21년도는 뭘 사도
올랐어요 지금 같은 시장에는 확실한
거 아니면은 안 사는게 낫습니다 내
건물주대 보겠다 해가지고 막 무리하게
투자하시는 분들 있는데 지금 같은
시기에는 굉장히 좀 위험한 시기라고
저는 생각이 듭니다 그리고 제안하고
싶은 한 가지요 어 좀 역동적으로
건물의 위치나 주변을 계속 보여줬으면
좋겠어요 빌사남 님 모습만 계속
나오면 지루해요 죄송합니다네 목소리만
나와도 좋을 듯합니다 그래서 저도
충분히 어떤 뜻인지 이해를 하고 어
좀 주변에 건물이라는 좀 이렇게
위치라든가 이런 거로 좀 주로 하고
저는 목소리만 나오겠습니다네 그리고
여의도 관련해서 제가 그때 영상
올렸었는데 감사합니다 그런데 그래서
강남을 뛰어 넘나요 이렇게 댓글 남겨
주셨는데 어 사실 지금 여의도에 뭔가
빌딩을 투자할 만한 그런 부지도 많이
없을 뿐더러 뭐 투자하기도 좀 쉽진
않고 뭐 아무리 이제 풀린다 하더라도
강남을 뛰어넘기는 좀 쉽지 않아
보입니다 빌사남 님 수년 정부도
구독하고 성장하시는 모습 보면서
응원하고 있습니다 뭐 멋있으세요 뭐
요즘 아파트 경매 물권은 기하
급수적으로 늘어나고 있는데 꼬마 빌딩
경매 물건 방향성은 어떻게 보시나요
그래서 그저 전에는 빌딩 이렇게
괜찮은 것들이 좀 경매로 많이 안
나오긴 했는데 전 앞으로 더 많이
나올 거 같아요 특히 24년도는 그
어느 때보다 경매 물건이 굉장히 좀
많아질 거 같고 경매로 낙찰 받기에는
좀 되게 좋은 시기인 거 같습니다
노후주택 디벨롭 언제까지 지속될까요
뭐 이렇게 남겨 주셨는데 노후 주택분
아니라 일단 땅의 가치가 괜찮은
것들을 개발하는 상황들은 그래도 뭐
계속 이어질 것 같긴 한데 근데 앞서
제가 영상에도 말씀드렸지만 지금 좀
임차 상황이 좀 많이 안 좋아요
그러다 보니까 기존에 이제 호환기 때
신축이나 리모델링 했던 거 근데
21년도 22년도 이제 지은 건물들이
이제 막 되긴 시작했는데 그런 공급이
되게 많아져서 지금 임차 상황이 좀
많이 안 좁습니다 땅으로 만약에
짓는다고 하면은 그런 부분까지도 좀
고려해야 될 거 같아요 그 전에는
무조건 만들어 놓으면 대부분 좀
들어가긴 했거든요 문의도 굉장히 많이
오고 최근에는 공급이 좀 많아져서
임차 상황이 전보다는 좀 매우 안
좋다 뭐 이렇게 보시면 될 거
같습니다 청담동 구축 빌라들이 향후
소규모 민간 재개발 가능성이
궁금합니다 어 최근에 아마 이희재 씨
기사를 보셨을 거예요 그래서 거기도
이제 에테르노 2를 개발하려고고
빌라들 다 매입했습니다 이런 개발하는
업체들이 청담동이면 좀 그래도
수익성이 괜찮거든요 잘 분양이 되기도
하고 저는 청담동에 뭔가 그런
지을만한 구축 빌라가 있다라고 하면은
그런 업체들에서 좀 살려고 하지
않을까 뭐 이렇게 조심스럽게 예상을
해봅니다네 그리고 여기서도 한 가지
말씀드릴게 재개발이란 재건축은 좀
달라요 재개발은 일대를 다 바꾸는
거예요 그니까 되게 낙후돼 있는
지역들을 개발하는게 이제 재개발이
재건축은 그 단지만 이제 새로 올리는
그런게 이제 제 건축이라고 보시면 될
거 같습니다이 구축빌라 같은 경우에도
재 건축이라고 보시면 될 거 같아요
빌사남 님이 보기에 초과 주택들이 잘
팔릴 거 같은지 뭐 아스턴이나 뭐
에테르나 앞구정 더피크 도상 같은
것들 빌사남 님 드은 하우스도
궁금하네요 뭐 이렇게 말씀해 주셨는데
이런 초고가 주택들 그런 수요가 있긴
하더라고요 뭐 에테르노 그렇고 이런
거 찾는 분들이 꽤 있었고 에테르는
원만 하더라도 처음에 한 100억
정도로 분양한다고 했을 때 야 이걸
누가 100억 회사 했는데 지금 거의
뭐 200억 아지 이제 거의 올라왔고
그 슈퍼리치 분들이죠 슈퍼리치 분들이
또 살 만한 이런 고급 주택들이 좀
한정된 있긴 하더라고요 청담동이나
이렇게 좀 한남동이 이런 좀 주요
지역에 되게 핫한 지역에 있는 이런
고급 주택들은 그래도 수요가 좀 계속
있는 거 같습니다 제가 봤을 때 저의
드림하우스는 한남더 1입니다 열심히
하겠습니다네 어
기는 내년 한 봄쯤 할 생각입니다
그래서 아마 빠르면 2월 말 아니면
3월쯤 할 예정이고 그것도 만약에
하게 된다면 따로 공지를 하도록
하겠습니다 그리고 내년에 되면 건물
자살자 자살자 속출할 듯합니다
반토막이 온다고 봅니다 월세보다 더
많은 금리의 공포가 얼마나 지옥인지
모르네요 이렇게 씀 자살자 자살자는
아닌 거 같고요 내년에는 저도 봤을
때 시장은 좀 안 좋을 거 같아요
내년에도네 안 좋을 거 같고 괜찮은
매물들이 좀 많이 나올 것 같긴
합니다 저는 내년에 부실징후 기업
아마 전 영상 보시면 나올 거예요
회계산 이명 찍었는데 부실징후 기업에
해당되는 기업들이 내놓는 부동산들이
좀 많아질 것 같아 네 신중하고
욕심보다는 정성이 보이는 분
감사합니다네 저는 제 개업을 준비
중인 공인중개사로서 소속 공인중개사
님을 채용 하려다 보니 고민이네요
대표님 중개 법인에는 공인중개사 님이
정말 많이 계신데 중 개업 공인
중개사의 계약을 어떻게 다 진행할 수
있는지 궁금해요 어 저는 일단
말씀드리면 지금 중개법인 대표는
문승환 대표님이 하고 계세요 근데 그
전까지 제가 5년 정도 했었는데
일단은 그런 계약들을 다 일일이
하기가 사실 쉽진 않지만 할 때마다
저뿐만 아니라 몇 명이 다 다여 명이
그런 서류 검토라는 법률 검토라는
이런 거를 다 끝낸 다음에 해서
지금까지 뭔가 중개 사고라는 중계
이슈가 없었던 거 같은데 이것도 좀
어느 정도 좀 시스템이 생기면은
그래도 하실 수 있습니다 처음에는 좀
힘들긴 했지만 진짜 밥 먹을 시간도
없었거든요 사인 하려고 직접 가니까
이게 어느 정도 시스템만 좀 갇히면
그래도 할 수 있습니다 강남역도시에빛
뭐 이렇게 했는데 강남역에 요즘
공실이 워낙 많아요 워낙 많고 또
소유주 분들이 되게 오래 전부터
소유하고 계셔서 지금 뭐 임차 상황이
안 좋아서 그냥 비어 놓으신 분들도
많아요 그냥 애매하게 임대 주면 뭐
갱신 요구권 있고 그런 부분도 있기
때문에 그냥 비어 놓으신 분도 많은데
이거는 뭐 케이스바이 케이스인 거
같습니다 건물 다 사서 망한다 그런게
아니라 진짜이 시기에 괜찮은 위치에
괜찮은 가격에 있는 거 사면 또
얘기가 달라질 수 있죠 건물주 10에
9는 100% 망한다 뭐 이렇게 하셨
이거는 그런 거 돼요 뭐 건물뿐만
아니라 뭐 주식도 그렇고 뭐 코인도
그렇고 뭐 어떤 상품이든간에 다
실패할 확률은 있습니다 뭐 호환기
때도 돈을 못 버신 분들도 있고요
이거는 뭐 무조건 100% 망한다 뭐
이런 거는 사실 의미가 없는 거
같습니다 덕분에 빌딩 투자로 400억
넘는 이익 실현을 했네요 앞으로도 잘
부탁드립니다 아 진짜
축하드립니다네 400억이
보셨다고네 나중에 뭐 어디에 이렇게
투자를 하셨는지 알려주시면 좋을 거
같습니다네 그리고 이건 플인데 영어
한 마디도 못
하 뭔 글로벌 있냐 뭐 어깨 있는
사람으로서 뭐 동종 없게 있으신
분인가 봐요 존나 웃기네 뭐 천억짜리
거래도 못 해본 놈들이 존나 깝치네
이렇게 돼 있는데 저 영화 못 해요
내 영어 못 하고 일부러 이렇게
올린게 더 잘하려고 올린 겁니다 그런
거 같아 그니까 사람들이 다 처음에는
다 무시를 하거든요 제가 그때
고등학생 때 선생님한테 한다 그랬을
때 선생님이 저한테 거의 진짜
욕했어요 네가 무슨 무슨 공인 중개
사냐 너 지금 할 수 있을 것 같냐
무시를 했었는데 땄습니다 오히려 이런
거는 저한테 더 좀 동기 부여도 되는
거 같고 더 열심히 해서 나중에 정말
유창한 영어로 영상을 찍을테니까 계속
좀 지켜봐 주세요 되게 거래 많이
하시는 분 같은데 어 너무
축하드립니다네 축하드리고 앞으로 더
열심히 할 겁니다네 영상을 쭉 보다
보니 대표님의 생각이 현실을 만들고
있는 생각이 드네요 댓글만 봐도 그걸
어떻게 하냐 불가능하다 이런 글이
보이는데 그렇게 생각하니까 못 하고
된다고 생각하니까 됩니다 김승호
회장님도 책에서 한국 사업가들이
아시아권에 진출후 미국 오는게
안타깝다고 한한 마리 생각나네요 미국
다이렉트로 진출해서 대박 나시길
기원합니다 아 그리고 죄송한
말씀이지만 5년 안에 뉴욕에서
성공한다는 아닐 것 같습니다 3년
봅니다 이렇게 쓰셨는데 진짜 모르는
거예요네 지금 제가 뭐 뉴욕을 뭐
진출하네요 을 수도 있지만 나중에
어떻게 될지 모릅니다 물론 잘 안 될
수도 있어요 저는 그런 꿈을 꾸는게
되게 중요하다라고 생각하거든요 지금
나는 뭐 뉴욕이나 해외 진출이 안 될
거다라고 하면 그냥 국내에서 그러고
그냥 끝날 겁니다 그게 아니라 뉴욕을
내가 가서 성공하지 않더라도 그
시장을 보고 더 큰 세상에 있다라는
자극도 좀 받고 진짜 거기 진출해서
뉴욕에서 잘될 수도 있거든요 그런
꿈을 갖는게 중요한 거지 그냥 무조건
안 될거다 난 안 될 거다라고 하면
그냥 패배자로 사는 거 입니다 그리고
전 아직 젊기 때문에 무엇이든 할 수
있다라고 생각해요 그 빌사남 처음에
그랬고 중개사도 그랬고 예전에
아무것도 없을 때도 그랬거든요
아무것도 없었는데도 다 이렇게
꿈꾸니까 됐어요 저는 계속 도전하고
나아갈 겁니다네 말들이 저를 더
자극하고 더 잘하고 싶고 그렇게 뭔가
동기 부여가 되니까 더 이렇게 좀
악불 그리고 이제 조언 같은 것도 해
주시면 좋을 것 같습니다 대표님
멋지세요 키까지 컸으면 사모님이
불안했을 때
항상 잘 보고 있습니다 감사합니다 어
그래서 뭐 키에 대한 컴플렉스가 있죠
예 제가 키가 딱 170이 그든 사실
키
컸으면 전 뭐 이미 결혼해서 끝났어요
키를 좀 와이프가 안 봐서 다행인 거
같아요네 와이프한테 항상 감사하고
항상 고맙다고 얘기하고 싶습니다 좀
되게 많은 분들이 댓글도 남겨 주시고
되게 악플도 많 뭐 이렇게 하지만
악플도 사실 관심이 있으니까 이렇게
달아 주신 거라고 저는 생각을 해서
그런 부분이 있으면 제가 좀 더
보완하고 좀 더 바뀌는 모습을 되게
좀 보여주고 싶습니다 어 앞으로 뭐
bsn 뭐 사남이 어떻게 될지
모르겠지만 그래 계속 꾸준히 노력하고
계속 변화하고 그런 모습들을 좀 보여
주고 싶어요 아마 내년 계획 중에
하난데 뭐 영어뿐만 아니라 몸도 좀
이렇게 키우고 싶어요 개인적으로
영어도 뭐 지금 아예 거의 못하지
하지만 변화하는 모습을 영상에 계속
답고 싶고 그리고 몸도 시작하기 전에
뭐 몸을 이렇게 날것도 보여주고 약간
것이라 기 그렇지만 운동하기 전
모습도 보여줘서 진짜 진짜 운동하면
이렇게 변한다는 것도이 영상으로
남기고 싶은 생각도 있어서 일단은
변화하고 좀 성장하는 모습을 계속
보여 드리려고 하니까 너무 밉게만
보여주 보지 마시고 어 일단 좀 계속
지켜봐 주시면 감사하겠습니다 영상은
여기까지 하겠습니다 자 감사합니다
여러분